WAI CHEE DIMOCK: We're moving
on to the
Fitzgerald stories, and I just
wanted to make an announcement
about a possible field trip
to New York City.
Merve Emre, one of the
teaching fellows, is
organizing a trip to see the
production of The Sun Also
Rises, which is another
novel by Hemingway.
It's by the Elevated--
what is the group called?
Elevator Repair Service.
So it's very interesting.
Last year, they did
The Great Gatsby.
It was right here
at the Yale Rep.
So it's a very interesting
group, and it looks like
they're going to keep on doing
these extended readings but
also dramatic readings
of the novel.
So if you guys would like to go
to see The Sun Also Rises,
just email Merve.
And I'm just going
to get started on
the Fitzgerald stories.
And we might be under the
mis-impression from reading
the short stories that maybe
Fitzgerald went to Yale.
He didn't.
He was Princeton,
Class of 1917.
And this is actually a very
interesting that I found from
the Princeton library.
That's a receipt that he had
at the Triangle Club.
And because so many of the short
stories have to do with
clubs, the Yale club, and so on,
it's interesting just to
have this document showing that
he was a member of the
Triangle Club.
And this is a letter that he
wrote to his classmate, also
Princeton 1917, Ludlow Fowler,
who would go on to become a
very prominent New York lawyer,
the founder of a very
prominent law firm.
This is what he wrote
to Ludlow Fowler.
"I have written a 15,000-word
story about you called 'The
Rich Boy.' It is in a large
measure the story of your
life, toned down here and
there and simplified.
Also, many gaps had to come
out of my imagination.
It is frank, unsparing, but
sympathetic, and I think you
would like it."
It's astonishing that he should
think so, that anyone
would actually like this story
if it's supposedly based on
their lives.
But in any case, this is what
authors sometimes think about
their own work.
So I think we know just from
our edition in the short
stories that there were a couple
of episodes that Ludlow
Fowler made Fitzgerald
take out.
They are reinserted now in
brackets, but obviously there
was historical proof that Ludlow
Fowler was pretty upset
by the story.
But in any case, Fitzgerald
really thought that this was a
story about a friend of his and
that the friendship was
what propelled him into
writing this story.
So it's also in that story that
he lays out his theory
about fiction and especially the
way that characters are to
be described in fiction.
So here's Fitzgerald.
"Begin with an individual, and
before you know it, you find
that you have created a type.
Begin with a type, and
you find that you
have created nothing.
There are no types,
no plurals.
There is a rich boy, and
this is his, and not
his brother's, story.
All my life, I have lived among
his brothers, but this
one has been my friend."
So still saying within the
story itself that this is
about someone who he still
calls his friend.
This is his theory.
Let's see what Fitzgerald does
in practice, because we know
that quite often there's a
distance between what authors
profess they're doing and what
they actually end up doing.
So this is his practice right
on the next page.
"Let me tell you about
the very rich.
They are different
from you and me.
They possess and enjoy early,
and it does something to them,
makes them soft where we are
hard and cynical where we are
trustful, in a way that, unless
you were born rich, it
is very difficult
to understand.
They think deep in their hearts
that they are better
than we are, because we have to
discover the compensations
and refuges of life
for ourselves.
Even when they enter deep into
our world or sink below us,
they still think that we are
better than we are."
So let's say a couple
of things here.
First, obviously, is that
Fitzgerald is using a type, a
social label.
He's turning a rich boy into a
social type and generalizing
about this entire social type.
So in many ways, he is doing
exactly what he says writers
should never do, proceeding
with a type.
But I think that we should also
say that given the fact
that he is using a type, that
the rich boy is a generic
identity that he honors, that
he recognizes as a reality,
that even though he is doing
that, the contents that he
attributes to that type
actually are pretty
interesting.
According to him, a rich boy,
or the rich, are people who
are different from people who
are not rich because of two
things, that they are soft where
we are hard and that
they are cynical where
we are trustful.
Those two actually pull in
two different directions.
If we were just to take the
first one, that they are soft
where we are hard, that's very,
very understandable,
that because they didn't have
to struggle all that much,
they don't have the kind of
hardihood that comes to people
when they have to struggle a
lot just to get the bare
essentials from life.
So that would be completely
understandable.
But what is interesting is that
right after that comes a
statement that completely is
on the other side of the
spectrum, that whereas the rest
of us are trustful, the
rich actually are cynical.
So how could this be?
Under what circumstances would
the rest of us be trustful,
whereas the rich would
be cynical?
This is not so self-evident.
It is something that Fitzgerald
would just throw
out as a generalization,
seemingly just something that
he would make-- a casual point
that he would make.
But actually it's
quite puzzling.
So we have to figure out in the
course of the story, "The
Rich Boy," why it is that even
though they're soft most of
the time, there are also moments
when they are actually
harder than we are, they
are more cynical
than the rest of us.
So in any case, all we can say
at this point is that even
though, yes, Fitzgerald uses
social types in his stories,
that he has a very interesting
understanding of
those social types.
So we can say that he's really
not so much subscribing to the
notion of social types as
playing with them, putting
pressure on them, looking at all
the possible permutations
of social types.
So this is something that we've
already talked about a
little bit last week when we
talked about To Have and Have
Not and Hemingway's use of those
two types, "have" and
"have not".
So today I want to go back a
little bit and give you in
many ways the genealogy to
that kind of thinking,
thinking in terms
of social types.
And it actually goes back to
the mid-nineteenth century.
This is a very famous text,
scientific text-- what aspires
to be a scientific text--
by Josiah Nott and
George Gliddon
called Types of Mankind.
And if you guys are fans of
Stephen Jay Gould, you'll see
that this text is actually
mentioned by Stephen Jay Gould
in his book Mismeasure of Man.
That's where I got my
information from.
So in 1854, the understanding--
there's a clear correlation,
obviously, between the facial
features of a Caucasian person,
a very Greek-looking
person, classical profile,
and this very flat facial
structure, bone structure
of the face.
The skull corresponds to
the facial features.
And then obviously the
implication is that blacks and
gorillas actually have the
same skull formation.
So we can see where
this is heading.
This is the sort of science that
is quite common in the
mid-nineteenth century, talking
about social types in
order to suggest a very close
kinship between certain types
of humans and certain
types of animals.
That's the impetus behind that
kind of taxonomic thinking.
So this was in the
mid-nineteenth century, and by
the twentieth century, that
pretty much has receded into
the background.
So let's look at another kind
of thinking about types.
And as we can see from this
very sober-looking,
no-thrills, no-nonsense look
of the treatise, this is a
very highly respected
sociological treatise by
Burgess, E. W. Burgess, and
Robert Ezra Park called
Introduction to the Science
of Sociology.
And it turns out that social
types, the notion of social
types, is crucial to the
birth of sociology.
So this is what Robert
E. Park says.
"I did not see how we could have
anything like scientific
research unless we had a system
of classification and a
frame of reference into which we
could sort out and describe
in general terms the things
we were attempting to
investigate."
So a system of classification
and a frame of reference into
which we should sort out and
describe in general terms.
Obviously, there's a degree of
extraction going on, a degree
of generalization going on.
We need to be able to generalize
from individual
cases in order to create a
system of classification.
So in many ways, that's the very
foundation of the science
called sociology.
And Fitzgerald, and Hemingway
as well, they were both very
much moving in that very
pervasive, very common
intellectual climate.
So I want to stop here for a
brief moment and talk a little
bit about the interconnections
among the texts that we've
read so far.
As you guys recognized last
week when we were talking
about To Have and Have Not, we
were talking about Harry
Morgan as a kind of tension--
the character is a tension
between a type, between label
of generic type and a
deviation from type.
And we mentioned that in fact,
it's only when he is mediated
through the presence of other
people, when he's channeled
through Marie or when he's
contrasted with Robert Gordon,
that he actually becomes
somebody who's
not a social type.
So that's Hemingway thinking
about type.
I also want to go back a little
bit further and refresh
your memory about The
Sound and the Fury.
In The Sound and the Fury,
we talked a lot about the
relation between today
and tomorrow.
Obviously, time is central to
The Sound and the Fury.
And we were talking about
Benjy's, Quentin's, and
Jason's tomorrow as one of the
most important things linking
the three brothers.
So today, what I would like to
do is to combine those two
analytic structures to create a
new structure to talk about
Fitzgerald's short stories.
We'll be talking about type and
variation, but mapped onto
the concept of the relation
between today and tomorrow.
So if you belong to a certain
type, if you can be labeled by
a generic identity, what is the
possible future for you?
What is the possible
tomorrow for you?
So basically a combination of
Hemingway and Faulkner.
But I also want to introduce
a new layer, a new analytic
layer into our discussion,
which is the difference
between a story that is dramatic
and a story that is
not dramatic.
And the four stories that we're
reading today represent
very interesting permutations
on that platform.
So we'll be talking
about that too.
And this is just a very quick
run through of the argument
that I'll try to make today.
"The Rich Boy" is about
excessive conformity to type.
Tomorrow is going to be exactly
like today, and so it
is not dramatic.
"Babylon Revisited" is in many
ways a kind of rewriting of
"The Rich Boy." It's about
someone who conforms to type
to a large extent, but not
entirely, and what happens
when that's the case.
And so tomorrow is not quite
like today, but still it's not
a dramatic story.
And then we move on two stories
that are very dramatic.
"The Diamond as Big as the
Ritz," as we know from the
title, it's large-scale drama.
It's very, very dramatic.
And then "Bernice Bobs Her
Hair," small-scale drama, but
also dramatic.
But let's take a closer look at
"Rich Boy." And even though
Fitzgerald went into Princeton,
for some reason
Yale is the reference
point for him.
So the Yale Club is
a social marker.
And it's very interesting that
actually Fitzgerald makes the
point that Anson Hunter actually
was not popular when
he was at Yale.
So Fitzgerald is making a
distinction between Yale
College in New Haven and the
Yale Club in New York City.
And he's really talking about
the Yale Club in New York City
and not so much Yale College.
So Anson is devoted
to the Yale Club.
He's always there.
But there's also the sense that
maybe it's too much of a
good thing.
And so there's the possibility
that excessive conformity to
type--he's the Yale
Club type--
that being too much of that
would actually lead to some
kind of deviation.
But first of all, this is the
devotion to the Yale Club.
"But he never abandoned
the Yale Club.
He was a figure there, a
personality, and a tendency of
his class, who were now seven
years of college, to drift
away to more sober haunts was
checked by his presence."
So this is a very unremarkable
sentence in many ways.
It's not something that
we would know.
It's very matter-of-fact.
It's very neutrally
descriptive.
He's a pillar of the Yale Club,
and his presence there
is an anchor for other
people, so they stick
around because of him.
So there's really nothing to
say one way or another,
really, about this description
of Anson Hunter, other than
the fact that it's a little odd
that seven years out of
college that the Yale Club
is still the very
center of his universe.
So it's just beginning to look
a little odd, but the
description in itself is not
especially dramatic or
noticeable, really.
But more towards the middle of
the story, in fact, after some
things have happened, we know
that he missed his chance to
marry Paula.
He misses his chance
to marry Dolly.
His life seems to be a catalogue
now of things that
are not done, the things that
he could've done, that he
chooses not to do, or
that he perversely
allows not to happen.
It is beginning to
look that way.
And it is at this moment that
the excessive devotion to the
Yale Club becomes almost a
summary of what kind of a
person he is.
"It was a hot Friday afternoon
in May, and as he walked on
the pier, he realized that
Saturday closing had begun,
and he was free until
Monday morning.
'Go where?' he asked himself.
The Yale Club, of course.
Bridge until dinner, then four
or five raw cocktails in
somebody's room and a pleasant,
confused evening."
It's still quite neutral.
It's not registering any shock
about this non-turn of events.
Basically, nothing happens
in Anson's life.
So all these things that could
have happened that would have
been a significant development
in his life, significant
turning points, all those
important turning points were
roads not taken by Anson.
And so he's still going
to the Yale Club.
But at this point, going to
the Yale Club becomes a
measure of the poverty
of his life.
Before, it had been a tribute to
the fact that he's such an
important presence there.
He's a pillar of
the Yale Club.
Now he's going there because he
doesn't have anything else.
So it's a description from being
a plus in his life--
something that he has on his
resume, that he's such an
important figure at the Yale
Club-- from being a plus on
his resume, it becomes not
exactly a minus, but a sign
that things are just starting
not to go well for him or that
we're beginning to see
that some things are
beginning to go wrong.
So it's an indication of a life
that is not taking shape
as it should.
And the story really is
about the possible
shapes of one's life.
If Anson had married Paula, it
would've taken a very, very
different shape.
It's the fact that he doesn't
allow his life to take that
shape that it retains the
original shape, which I guess
is good in one sense-- it wasn't
such a bad shape to
begin with--
but the fact remains that
there's absolutely no change
in his life, that tomorrow is
going to be exactly like
yesterday and like today.
So this is the very
end of the story.
And this is on a boat.
And the narrator is actually
happy that things have--
that this is how things
stand for Anson.
"And he told me about the girl
in the red tam and his
adventures with her, making them
all bizarre and amusing,
as he had a way of doing, and I
was glad that he was himself
again, or at least the self that
I knew and with which I
felt at home.
I don't think he was ever happy
unless someone was in
love with him, responding to
him, like filings to a magnet,
helping him to explain himself,
promising him something.
What it was, I do not know.
Perhaps they promised that there
would always be women in
the world who would spend the
highest, freshest, rarest
hours to nurse that superiority
he cherished in
his heart."
So it is in many ways a portrait
of a social type.
It really comes back to that
recognizable social profile,
someone who, because he has such
a large and guaranteed
and very, very secure income--
he's very, very successful in
his firm, and he's the pillar,
the head of his family--
because so many things are a
given in his life, what is
also a given is the
understanding that there would
always be a supply of women who
would gravitate towards
him and be bowled over by him.
People were still bowled over by
him if they'd just see him
for the first time.
And it's that capacity, that
knowledge, that certainty that
there would always be women who
would be bowled over by
him that makes him what he is.
So Fitzgerald's definition of
the rich boy extends far
beyond the amount of money that
Anson Hunter has, even
though that is not an
unimportant consideration.
But it really is in many ways
the starting point for a whole
psychological profile about
what it means when someone
takes a lot of things for
granted and the ways in which
taking so many things for
granted can actually be a
psychological liability.
It's actually not good for us,
according to Fitzgerald, to be
able to take so many things for
granted, especially for
people to take other human
beings for granted.
And that is exactly the
most fundamental
truth about Anson Hunter.
So it is about a social type.
There's no question about it.
But there's the paradox that he
becomes almost kind of an
extreme test case of a very
recognizable social profile.
Just to show what a range
Fitzgerald has and the way
that he can start at almost
exactly the same starting
point but end up in a different
place, I thought
that maybe we should look at
"Babylon Revisited." It's also
about a rich man, someone who's
never eaten in a cheap
restaurant in Paris.
I think that that really is
raising the bar very high.
It's not like we go to
Paris every day.
But never to have eaten in a
cheap restaurant in Paris, so
that is the threshold
for Charlie.
And it would be all too easy to
suggest, OK, here's another
rich boy and this conformity
to type.
What is also interesting about
Charlie is that he has in
common with Anson the
fact that they
both are hard drinkers.
So four or five martinis
is really nothing.
It's just the norm.
It's just the beginning,
really.
So the hard drinking, the taking
things for granted, the
lack of variety in the
experience, all of those
things they have in common.
Because they are so rich,
all of those things
they have in common.
But what is interesting about
Charlie is that, in fact, his
life has a very, very different
trajectory from that
of Anson's.
And it is actually
a happy ending.
So let's see what happens at
the very end of Charlie's
story, "Babylon Revisited."
"He went back to his table.
His whiskey glass was empty,
but he shook his head when
Alix looked at it
questioningly.
There wasn't much he could
do now except send
Honoria some things.
He would send her a lot
of things tomorrow.
'No, no more,' he said
to another waiter.
'What do I owe you?' He would
come back someday.
They couldn't make
him pay forever.
But he wanted his child, and
nothing was much good now
beside that fact.
He wasn't young anymore, with
a lot of nice thoughts and
dreams to have by himself.
He was absolutely sure Helen
wouldn't have wanted him to be
so alone."
So right here, we can see a lot
of very, very important
differences between
Charlie and Anson.
The first thing we notice is
that this is someone who's
stopped drinking.
That is such an obvious fact
that it's almost embarrassing
to point out, but there it is.
It is very important for
Fitzgerald, who had a problem
with alcoholism, that that
should be the case, that this
person has enough self-control
to say no when it would have
been so easy to say yes.
But more than that, that
is actually just the
manifestation of something being
different, is that he
has one very important
person in his life.
And what is interesting is that
this is actually not a
romantic interest. So what is
missing in Anson Hunter's life
is a child.
And we know that Fitzgerald
himself had said many things
about his daughter, Scottie,
that it broke his heart to
think that when Scottie grew up,
that his novels would no
longer be in print.
He said that about
The Great Gatsby.
So we do know that Fitzgerald
had a personal knowledge of
what it means to have a child
and to think about the future
in terms of the future of that
child and wanting to share a
future with that child.
I think that that actually is
what gives him a future.
So we're actually very close
to the world of To Have and
Have Not, which is the future
appearing by virtue of the
mediation of someone else.
In this case, it is not Harry's
wife, Marie, who
enables that future,
an affirmative
future, to take shape.
It is not his wife but his
daughter, Honoria.
So his future is defined in
terms of today, I'm going to
give her some things.
Tomorrow, I'm going to give
her a lot more things.
It's the pleasure of being able
to give his daughter a
lot of presents, that is what
makes him work hard.
He's very, very good at his
job making tons of money.
He's very, very trusted
by his employers.
It is all of that that's giving
him a certain kind of
relation to time.
So in that way, I think both
Hemingway and Faulkner are
sort of implicitly present
in the story.
It's how do we get to stop
being a social type?
And how do we get to have
a personal and a highly
interestingly populated relation
to the future?
The future is not any
good unless it is
populated by something.
And in this case, Charlie's
future is very much populated
by his daughter.
And that is because of the way
it is populated that he wants
to get to that future.
If it's not populated,
you might not
even want to go there.
You might want just to
stay where you are.
But if it's populated in such
an interesting way, he does
want to go there, and he wants
to go there with her.
So this is the main difference
between Charlie and Anson.
And what is also interesting
is it enables him to think
about his wife, Helen, who
died in very difficult
circumstances when they were
reconciled, but not really.
It was not a good marriage.
It was through the mediation of
his daughter that he's able
to think about his wife, who
he had probably wronged in
some sense.
But she's dead now.
There's no way for him
to right that wrong.
So the only way he can right
that wrong that otherwise
would have been permanent is
once again through the
mediation of his daughter.
So a mediated personal identity
and a mediated
relation to the future.
And so these are the two stories
that I should say that
they have a lot in common in
terms of the narrative
structure of the stories.
Because even though it's a
happy ending for Charlie,
because the future is going to
happen so slowly, it's a very
slow happening, slow
pace, incremental
emergence of tomorrow.
He's going to give money
to his sister-in-law.
That's the implication that's
how he would get
his daughter back.
He's going to pay for
everything to get
his daughter back.
He's going to give his daughter
lots and lots of presents.
So all of that is going to
happen one day after another.
There's not going to be a
dramatic change in his life.
It's strictly incremental.
But because it is steadily
incremental, we know that his
distant future will actually
be significantly different
from the today.
But neither of those stories,
would I say,
neither is really dramatic.
So let's turn now to the other
side of the narrative
spectrum, two stories that are
very, very dramatic, and one
advertising the drama in the
title, "The Diamond as Big as
the Ritz."
So we know this is probably the
most famous short story by
Fitzgerald, and I would
encourage you to discuss in
section whether or not that is
indeed your favorite story.
It's certainly very,
very unforgettable.
So this off-the-charts deviation
from an extreme type
rich boy and drama on a large
scale, obviously.
The catastrophe at the end of
the story, tomorrow is going
to be different today.
But let's just look at the way
Fitzgerald proceeds to talk
about this very, very
extravagant world that really
truly is nothing like the
world as we know it.
"St. Midas' School is half
an hour from Boston in a
Rolls-Pierce motorcar.
The actual distance will never
be known, for no one except
John T. Unger had ever arrived
there save in a Rolls-Pierce,
and probably no one
will ever again."
This is on the same page as
"never having eaten in a cheap
restaurant in Paris."
So that is the norm.
The norm itself is very,
very extreme.
It's the most expensive boarding
school in the world,
and it's unheard of for anyone
to go there and not owning a
Rolls-Royce or Rolls-Pierce.
So that is the baseline, a very,
very high threshold.
But even on that very
high threshold,
Percy is still a deviation.
So it's definitely a deviation
from an extreme type.
And one measure of that
deviation is the kind of car
owned by the family.
So when they got to Montana,
John sees that there's this
luminous disk that's
coming at him.
He has no idea what that is.
"Then as they came closer, John
saw that it was the tail
light of an immense automobile,
larger and more
magnificent than anything
he had ever seen.
Its body was of gleaming metal
richer than nickel and lighter
than silver, and the hubs of the
wheels were studded with
iridescent geometric figures
of green and yellow.
John did not bear to guess
whether they were glass or
jewel."
I just want to stop for a
moment and talk about a
possible paper topic that would
be perfect for the paper
that is ten pages, which is the
automobile in Fitzgerald
and Faulkner.
We know that Jason can't stand
the smell of gasoline, that he
has terrible headaches
because of his
relation to the gasoline.
So it's a very interesting take
on cars on Faulkner's
part, and we know that
Fitzgerald certainly
dramatizes and turns Gatsby's
Rolls-Royce into a surreal
car, a mythic car.
And here he's coming
back to that.
So using the car as a very, very
concrete point of entry,
we can actually talk about very
large structures in both
Faulkner and Fitzgerald.
To what extent is
the Rolls-Royce
an emblem of Gatsby?
We also know that they saw
another car with two black men
and a black woman in a car
driven by a white chauffeur.
That's part of the
story as well.
That's the configuration.
So we can use the very concrete
object, a very
well-defined object, the car,
and talk about the symbolic
constellation revolving
around that car.
In the case of Fitzgerald,
definitely it would be a
social landscape,
the Jazz Age.
And in the case of Faulkner, it
actually has to go back to
the relation between the
nineteenth century and the
twentieth century, so the
horse as a relic of the
nineteenth century being played
off the automobile.
So using the car, you can write
a great paper that would
be very specific and that would
move from a small focus
to a large argument.
So I would encourage you in
writing your papers to think
of similar structures.
Start from something extremely
well-defined and then move on
to something larger.
But in any case, as we can see,
actually, Fitzgerald is
really fascinated
by the relation
between cars and race.
So the car is memorable in
here, in this story, "The
Diamond as Big as the Ritz." And
it turns out that it also
has a very important
racial dimension.
We know that the black
characters are still slaves in
this story.
And they were originally brought
from the South, and
they had always been in the
possession of the family.
So this is what happens
to this black slave.
"All these Negroes are
descendants of the ones my
father brought north with him.
There are about 250 now.
You notice that they've lived
so long apart from the world
that their original dialect
has become an almost
indistinguishable patois."
And he goes on to say that he
actually trains a few of them
just to speak English so that
they can communicate with the
rest of the world.
But all of the rest, the 250
of them, actually speak a
patois, or a dialect, that has
no relation or is so far
removed from English that it
would not be a recognizable
language to English speakers.
So that in itself is almost like
a little local allegory
for the relation of this
particular family, the
Washington family, and the
unsustainable relation between
today and tomorrow.
You can't keep on in the middle
of the United States
speaking a language that is
supposedly English that really
has no relation to the English
spoken by everyone else.
It's just not a viable way of
living in the United States.
Thinking that you're still
speaking English when yours
isn't recognized as English
by anyone else is not a
sustainable linguistic
relation.
And it's also an unsustainable
relation between this one
closed world that wants to
remain closed and the rest of
the United States that is
dynamically expanding and also
trying to integrate all locales
into a national grid.
So this is what happens when
we notice that there's one
important aspect of the
Washington family that is
clearly not going
to last forever.
And this patois is not going
It's going to die out.
It's going to be contaminated
by the
living English language.
That this is going to die out,
what else is going to die out
about the family?
What else is going to die out
about this particular setup,
this closed world that
fantasizes about
being closed forever?
And we see very soon that in
fact the end is going to come
faster than we think.
It only takes a few pages,
really, for the end to arrive,
and it's drama on a very,
very large scale indeed.
"Simultaneously, and with an
immense concussion, the
chateau literally threw itself
into the air, bursting into
flaming fragments as it rose,
and then tumbling back upon
itself in a smoking pile that
lay projecting half into the
water of the lake.
There was no fire.
What smoke there was drifted
off mingling with the
sunshine, and for a few minutes
longer, a powdery dust
of marble drifted from the great
featureless pile that
had once been the
house of jewels.
There was no more sound, and the
three people were alone in
the valley."
So the ending in many ways
is not surprising.
It's a very interesting
combination.
On the one hand, it's
highly dramatic.
On the other hand, there's an
element of predictability to
that drama.
We almost know that some
catastrophe is going to happen
at the end of the story.
And I think that Fitzgerald is
actually very comfortable with
that kind of combination,
high drama, but
with almost no suspense.
We know almost from the very
beginning that probably
something very, very bad
is going to happen at
the end of the story.
And we also know from the very
desolate landscape at the end
of the story that the tomorrow
is going to be totally
different from the today
within the story.
So I have to confess that I like
this story a lot, but I
actually like drama on
a smaller scale.
So "Bernice Bobs Her Hair" is
actually my favorite story
among the Fitzgerald stories.
And I hope that you'll
see why.
It's about reversion
to an original type
and an unknown future.
So Fitzgerald I think really
liked the story as well, so
that is the story that is
featured on the cover of the
collection of short stories
Flappers and Philosophers.
And if the word "flapper," if
that doesn't ring a bell right
away, this is an image of the
very famous flappers of the
1920s, people who bobbed their
hair and wear short skirts,
show their legs, and so on.
So the flapper.
So you guys know that the story
is really about someone
who's becoming a flapper.
Bernice is going to--
has in fact cut off all her
beautiful hair, tons and tons
of hair, has it cut off.
But it turns out that
that's exactly the
wrong hairdo for her.
She's very, very ugly after
that, and her beaus stop--
her beaus lose all
interest in her.
And she has one person
to thank, her cousin.
So this is what happens to the
person that she has to thank.
Her cousin, Marjorie, is
sleeping, and this is what
happens to Marjorie
when she's asleep.
"Bernice deftly amputated the
other braid, paused for an
instant, and then flitted
swiftly and silently back to
her own room.
After a minute's brisk walk, she
discovered that her left
hand still held the
two blond braids.
She laughed unexpectedly, had to
shut her mouth hard to keep
from emitting an
absolute peal.
She was passing Warren's house
now, and on the impulse, she
set down her baggage, and
swinging the braids like
pieces of rope flung them at the
wooden porch, where they
landed with a slight thud.
She laughed again, no longer
restraining herself. 'Huh!'
she giggled wildly.
'Scalp the selfish thing!'"
So it really is in one
sense no big deal.
Hair will grow out.
Bernice's hair will grow out.
Marjorie's hair will
also grow out.
So cutting off somebody's braids
is not like the end of
the world, as it is in "The
Diamond as Big as the Ritz."
But still it's an interesting
kind of drama.
And what makes the drama
especially interesting is the
fact that Bernice actually uses
the word "scalp," which
is a word not used in the
twentieth century.
It goes all the way back to
the nineteenth century,
eighteenth century.
It had to do with a Native
American practice.
So in order to understand this
odd use of language, I think
that we need to, with the help
of another sociologist and
anthropologist, very well
known, one of the most
important thinkers, really, in
the late nineteenth century
extending into the twentieth
century, many authors--
Zora Neale Hurston actually
studied with
Franz Boas at Columbia.
So Franz Boas had an interesting
argument about
human types as well.
And it turns out that he
is turning the notion
of type on its head.
And this is what he
says in 1911.
"When, for instance, it is
claimed that certain types of
Europeans show better mental
endowment than other types of
Europeans, the assumption is
that these types are stable
and cannot undergo far-reaching
changes when
placed in a new social or
geographical environment.
An investigation of this
problem shows that the
assumption of an absolute
stability of human types is
not plausible."
So Franz Boas says that, OK, it
looks like-- on the face of
it, it looks like there
are different
types of human beings.
And yes, when we look at human
faces, there really are
different human types,
clearly undeniable.
But he doesn't think that
there's any permanence to
those types, that in fact, even
though you might be born
into one type, when you're put
in a different social or
geographical environment,
that type actually
gets radically modified.
So it is very much an argument
about the importance of
environmental input and the way
it can change your initial
genetic makeup.
And to prove his point, Franz
Boas actually became a
performance artist. So this is
Franz Boas dressed up as an
Inuit, otherwise known
as Eskimo --
to show that, yes, a Caucasian
man can look
just like an Inuit.
And here he is dressed up or
not dressed up at all as a
Native American and proving
that, yes, a Caucasian can
look like a Native American.
There is no permanent social
type, no permanent biological
or genetic type.
There's the constant shifting
of boundaries among those
types as well as the possibility
of the person of
one type taking on the identity
of another type.
So I think that that is the
context for understanding the
very odd use of the
word "scalp"
on the part of Bernice.
And it turns out that Fitzgerald
has actually
prepared us for that
development.
Much earlier in the story, when
they were actually just
talking about--
Bernice is being totally dull
and having nothing interesting
to say and just sitting around
all day and doing nothing and
being totally boring.
When they were talking about her
in that context, Marjorie
actually has this interesting
theory, that maybe she's so
dull and boring and submissive
because she's just like one of
the Native American women.
"'I think it is that crazy
Indian blood in Bernice,'
continued Marjorie."
So when she was saying that,
making that observation at
that point, is that Bernice
is really like the Native
American women.
But it turns out that, yes, she
has some Indian blood in
her, but what she resembles is
not the Indian woman but the
Indian warrior.
And that is really what's coming
out in that dramatic
amputation of Marjorie's
braids.
So the language, of course,
is mock-heroic.
It is using the language of
high drama to talk about
something that really is
a very small incident.
But nonetheless, it's a very
interesting story, and it's
the only story where we
don't know what the
future is going to be.
That Bernice has done this
thing that is out of
character, we just don't know
what the future will hold,
whether she will keep on this
path, that this is just the
beginning of a new career and
a new personal identity for
her, or whether she would revert
actually back to the
very quiet, very submissive
type that she was before.
So this is the only story, I
think, where we truly don't
know if the tomorrow is going
to resemble today.
And I think that it has to
do partly with that very
unexpected reversion to
an original type.
So the least we can say is that
Fitzgerald is someone who
really plays on all the possible
permutations of
social types.
I can't think of anybody more
inventive or having more to
bring to that kind
of permutation.
So we're done with Fitzgerald,
and on Thursday, we'll move on
to Faulkner and As I Lay Dying.